Jason Bourne is directed by Paul
Greengrass and stars Matt Damon Tommy
Lee Jones Alicia vikander Julia Stiles
if you've been paying attention to my
channel lately you will have seen that I
reviewed every single Jason Bourne Matt
Damon movie leading up to this movie if
you were really paying attention you
would have seen that I loved all three
of them the Bourne trilogy I'm excluding
Bourne Legacy the Bourne trilogy is one
of my favorite trilogies these are
fantastic action movies so naturally I
was pumped out of my mind that Paul
Greengrass is returning with Matt Damon
once again to tell another chapter in
this man's life and since I don't want
to spoil anything because the trailers
are very vague I will just say that
Bourne is trying to uncover certain
secrets of his past certain things that
are very personal to him that he now has
knowledge of is setting him on a revenge
path to try to learn exactly who is
responsible for certain things that
happened so going to this movie I was
just yes just this please be good please
I need it I need it I need it and this
movie starts very strong there is a
fantastic motorcycle chase during a riot
it is absolutely visceral it is so very
exciting I love this opening it was very
fast-paced it hooks you almost instantly
some things occur during this chase that
also hook you emotionally and you're
like yes this is going to be damn great
I am ready let's do this we learn more
about Alicia vikander character we learn
more about Tommy Lee Jones character and
then we get into the real story of the
film the meat of this movie there's this
subplot involving someone who's
launching this new form of social media
that has people concerned about privacy
and a lot of the film is dedicated to
this and about halfway through this
movie I said in my head this is the
worst of the Matt Damon ones isn't it
yep it is this is by no means a bad
movie it is light years beyond the
Bourne Legacy it is better directed
there are better action sequences it's
better acted it has a better story it is
just easily the worst of the Matt Damon
Barnes and one of the biggest reasons is
because this story is not very
compelling and I love the Bourne films
for their action and this movie
absolutely has fantastic action
sequences that opening motorcycle chase
is
awesome there's an amazing car chase
there's a fantastic fight scene the
action in this movie is not what
disappointed me what disappointed me is
the story is just not that riveting
there's definitely a revenge aspect to
this movie not just from the hero's
perspective but also from the villain
which was very unexpected and that added
something to the movie but the entire
story surrounding this social media guru
who's about to launch this platform that
has people concerned about invasion of
privacy grinds this film to a halt every
time it is brought up and it's brought
up a lot and I got to say usually when I
tell you guys that a movie is good I'm
happy about that
I'm very excited about the fact that I
just saw a good movie but this movie
should have been much better than good
this should have been spectacular the
action sequences are they really are
this is a very competent awesome and fun
action movie with a great performance
for Matt Damon a great performance from
Tommy Lee Jones and maybe the best
performance in the whole movie from
Alicia vikander this movie is filled
with great performances strong direction
and technically proficient action scenes
but I got to say that dialogue just
wasn't that compelling as a huge fan of
the Bourne movies I am disappointed this
movie should have been a viscerally
entertaining experience that wasn't just
a great action movie but also a very
good story and what they try to do
there are morsels of yes go in that
direction now forget about the damn
social media shit go in the direction
you're going now yes stay in this path
yes oh we're back to speeches about the
social media platform why why was that
such a focus in this movie it grinded
this story to a halt this movie should
have been a straight-up revenge movie
and when it was it was compelling when
it wasn't it was boring I really enjoyed
the Jason Bourne film overall from an
action standpoint from a performance
standpoint but in comparison to identity
supremacy and ultimatum this is a
disappointment it still is good though
this isn't a bad movie it's not like
Indiana Jones and the Kingdom of the
Crystal Skull disappointing like that
movie is actually kind of bad this movie
is at least good it has fantastic scenes
and great
Orman says and very strong direction but
the story just wasn't as compelling or
as riveting as it should have been and I
left disappointed still I am gonna give
Jason Bourne
Abey Abey for a born I got nothing
I got nothing sorry I got nothing
disappointing honestly a good movie a
movie that I will buy on blu-ray a movie
that I can actually tell you to go see
but like I said this should have been
much better considering the talent and
the films that came before it I am
hoping that they make another one and
that they lock down the story and just
make it be about this character who
gives a shit about this social media
thing what the hell was that just just
know just make it be about Jason Bourne
have it just do something with it is it
add a little I don't know guys I'm sorry
so this Sunday now that my Jason Bourne
series of reviews is done if you want to
watch them all they're on my channel
right now my next series of reviews is
starting leading up to fantastic beasts
and where to find them and that is going
to be every single Harry Potter movie I
can't wait to review these movies I am a
fan of the franchise and I have not
reviewed these films before so starting
this Sunday Harry Potter and the
Sorcerer's Stone is going to be up I'm
looking forward to that also it is time
to present the finale of our Jason
Bourne skit we had a great time filming
this
you will notice probably some homage is
and tributes to every single Jason
Bourne film in the trilogy throughout
this skit certain moments we try to have
fun with and give little nods to if you
want to know what happened at the
beginning of this skit you can watch my
review for the Bourne Ultimatum here we
go
you know we have your ticket to Jason
Bourne
we just need to know if you have a
digital copy
look I know you're trying to be a badass
and everything but you're gonna play
ball when we the other sir do you still
have them there yes sir
he's a high-priority asset and Jason
board is completely sold out here
I need that ticket
don't you please I just make the coffee
I know where they're dropping your
ticket
I can take either
we're gonna tell me what I need to know
all right swear to god I'm going to kill
you
why are you helping me
you know what I recognized you
yeah you're that coffee girl aren't you
why are you doing this huh
you know no one's coming to save you
again why are you helping me
one I don't like being coffee girl -
we're married
No
we're married what just not